there's more good news about Buffalo
Bills player Demar Hamlin doctors
treating him said he's awake and he has
made substantial progress as he receives
treatment following a cardiac arrest on
the football field Monday and last night
the NFL said the matchup between the
bills and the Cincinnati Bengals will
not be rescheduled but the bills will
play against the New England Patriots
this Sunday their last regular season
game chief medical correspondent Dr John
lapuke has more on Hamlin's recovery
the doctors overseeing Demar Hamlin's
treatment said he was quickly
resuscitated on the field first with CPR
then defibrillation before being
intubated in an ambulance and rushed to
the ICU when he woke up Wednesday
evening that fast action appeared to
have paid off it's not only that the
lights are on we know that he's home
though Hamlin was unable to talk because
of his breathing tube doctors said he
has been able to communicate in writing
even asking who won the game the answer
is yes you know Demario you won you've
won the game of Life yeah man he
definitely won the game in life
Bengal's receiver T Higgins was tackled
by Hamlin just moments before the Bill's
safety went to cardiac arrest and said
he's been in touch with Hamlin's family
since the incident occurred and it was
another big relief you know off of my
chest just knowing that he's responsive
the Bengals were back on the practice
field Thursday as were the bills I think
putting that helmet back on today was a
really good thing for our team but I'd
be lying to you if I didn't say you know
some people would be changed forever you
know after being on the field and
witnessing that Bill's quarterback Josh
Allen said the good news brought a lot
of tears of joy and head coach Sean
McDermott said Hamlin's father has
encouraged the team to stay the course
his message was
um
the team needs to get back to
focusing on the goals that they had set
for themselves Demar would have wanted
it that way
wow power of prayer Miracle of modern
medicine Dr lepuc you were on that call
with doctors yesterday first of all they
had some great lines Nate and I've been
cracking up all morning what did you
take away from it medically
cautious optimism right I mean we found
out a little more about the tick tock he
went down initially and he had a pulse
he lost the pulse they started doing CPR
immediately we were told and then after
a cycle of CPR he got defibrillated was
taken to the ambulance where he got
intubated and taken to the hospital
right now the biggest challenge they say
or a big challenge is his lungs he has a
condition called ards acute respiratory
distress syndrome where you have
inflammation in the lungs following an
event like this and that's why he's
still on the breathing tube he's not
talking because he has that tube that
goes past his vocal cords but he's
writing on the pad and he's nodding his
head yes or no so things are looking
good all signs are good not totally out
of the way
that's right Dr little poop thank you so
much